Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Outlast.
We are currently shimmying on the outside of the school building
because for some reason we were tossed in here....
AGAIN
Don't know why but here we go
And uh, I have no idea what you're talkin about, nothing's different so let's just focus on the game here
And where we're going with it
Cause...
I don't knooOOow if we're getting any sort
of progress here
It seems like we've just been kinda
Like dancing around the same subject, not necessarily going in circles but maybe that's paaAAARHT of it
well OKAY this is what I was talking about here
Like this EXACT CONCEPT was what I was talking about
We all know what happened, we just don't know the circumstances of WHY(We probably don't want to know)
and how it came to be, and oh my gahd
oh my GAHD
uhhhhhhhhhhh
alrighty then(You don't get to see him creeped out very often.Oh wait,you always get to see him creeped out)
Where do we go from here?!(I don't know)
EUUUUUUGH
EUUuuUuuUugh
WHY...?
oh OH that's why
I was about to- OOOH OKAY
Alright you really threw that down in a fit of rage,
didn't ya?
mmmmm you showed that what for
OKAY...
carry-(carry what:) )
what..?
I heard that
oh, hello!
ah,
Good.
Okay.
Hi.
Why am I in here?
What's going on in here?
What is that?
oh, TV remote
Nothin important
Ho kaY
Alright I guess that was nothing then. I just heard someone squeaking open a door and assumed it was gonna be BAAAD for me
Okay but it was good because I got a battery out of it and everything's gonna be hunky dory now.
Helloooo
Hiiii
My name is Markiplier- oh good! Another view of this one.
Oh, hi. I saw that.
I saw that you can't hide from me!
I know where you live!
oooooooh it's coming back
ooh
I see, I se- I see you
What are you doing there?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
Are you just waiting for me at the other place?
Oh you are, aren't ya
oh YOU ARE
oh you're waiting for me
Oh it's right around the corner and it's WAITING for me
uh oh
well that's not good
HELLO
This should be comforting and reassuring
hello
let's see
"Jessica...
Loves..
Blake"
OH!!!
She does? Oh, Blake loves Jessica back!
Even though apparently their relationship was falling apart...
Which is awfully nice (wait what). Hey, look! It's my recordings.
Alright, hello.
hello?
eugh
Is that Colin Mochrie?
*laughing* Is th- Is that Colin Mochrie right there?
okay, I KNOW
YOU'RE THERE
I KNOW YOU'RE THERE
unless you're behind me?
No, I know- I know you're there. Hang on, give me a second.
See if there something to be doOOOOH
Well that opened with more prominence than I assumed it would
Is there gonna be shoosting blood out of these?
alright okay
I'm always hesitant
but apparently there was no reason for coming in here
What about the girls one?
*whispering* Yeah I got a bad feeling about this one
yeAH I got A rEAL baD FEELING ABOUT THIS ONE
Hello?
Uh, eenie meenie miney mOE
ooOh
"Jessica" x7
"Jessica"
OH WAIT NO. "JESSICA LOVES BLAKE" OHHHH
aaaaaa...
"acissej"
ohhhh
LYNN IS WHO MY WIFE IS.. oh nooo
ohh noo
oh good a bandage
oh I'm sure that's SO sanitary
wait, so JESSICA loved Blake
but then it was not meant to be.. oh that's good
okay, I'm gonna come see you NOW
WAIT THATWASSOMETHINGBEHINDME
OH MY GOD
*sighs*
oh oh awwh oh awh oh awh oh oh awh oh oh aWH OH OH AWH OH OH OH OOooOoOHHH
oh I don't like the shadow work you're doing on me
oh I don't like that at all, hey how ya doin okay
alright
you guys...
youuuuu....
heyyyyy...
ohhhh so nice
alrighty then
Carrying on..
Hello
Back in the lib-
oh it was a ticking clock I thought that it was something else
Achievment unlocked: Scared by a clock
alrighty then
hello
hello?
uh, hello?
h- hello
h- hellooo?
anybody in here? helloo? h- hellOOO?
okay
I'm seeing a whole lot of nothing here
HEYYYY OH GOD
AH, AH, IT'S DARK IN HERE
WHERE- HOW DID I GET HERE?
YUEGH YEUGH YEUGH OHHH NOOOOOO
can i hide?
I don't think I can hide
oh this isn't gonna do me any good is it
just gonna crouch down here
pretend like I don't exist
hello?
uh h- hello?
WEELL...
Did something happen or am I okay?
I don't know but I'm gonna go out there cuz i'm a brave boi
hello?
Well I don't see anything anymore
okay.. nothin in here
ALRIGHT
Trusting ya
Trustin yuh
I don't know why I'm trusting ya I shouldn't trust ya
That's like the number one rule in this game is "Don't trust anything"
alright here we go
I suppose
Yep, here we go
Into the light OHHHHH GOOOD
*heavy breath*
alright there's nothing here, wait what was that
uhh, "Explore the mysteries, Stay Pure with new techniques"
I don't know if that's a good- good word of advice but I'm gonna try to go out of here
Cause I don't see why...
why I needed to come this way if it was just all gonna be OHH
OH THERES MORE
oh I didn't know there was gonna be more
No one told me there was gonna be more
awh ooooh
oh no
oh no OH NO
OH NO what kind of library is this
OH NO
(DEEEEEP BREATHS)
that scared the ever loving BAJEEZUS OUT OF ME
don't do that
don't do that to me
don't do that again
FOOL ME ONCE
SHAME ON ME
FOOL ME TWICE SHAME YOU
REAL HARD
FOOL ME THRICE- AY FUCK OFF WITH YOU
shame me the hardest you've ever..
is that a swastika?
OH HI
okay
I've been shamed
I don't know which way to go
but I'm gonna try to go and not
go the ways that are not
gonna leT ME GO THE WAY I NEED TO GO
HOOP
OH GOD DAMMIT
YEEEUUUGHHHEEGH
did I make it? oh shit
uh oh
okay
oh kay
These are all dead ends
But I don't see the goopy on the ground anymore
which makes me think maybe I got away from it
Soooo
That's good?
Question mark?
okay...
OH NOOO
OHHHHH NOOO
oh boy
oh kay
yeah this seems-
yaohwoah
faith?
history
gooooOOod
so much knowledge!!!
oh boy that looks bad
anytime something's covered in frosted glass, I know that they're trying to HIDE something
[weird voice] which usually means that I'm gonna be dead
very soon but I'm not gonna go THAT way
Imma go this way
HEY
hi
I see you there
Whaddya doin' ?
Hello!
Hello?
OOOhhh
B'alright.
B'okay.
B'oKAY
B'okay I'm gonna believe th-AAII
ffuuuckin
*smacks mouth x7*
UUUUuuughhhhh
EUugh fuckin you
FUCKin you
just FUCKING YOUUU
oh, what is with THIS
ohh why is this geometry all fuckernutted?
*grunt*
ohh boy. oohH GOOD. OH GOOD! OH GOOD!
Is something gonna happen? somethin behind me??
ooh
okay
aLRIGHT
Normal
Normal everydAYOCCURENCES HEY HEYY
yyYEE
Hi! SAVEME
JESSICA!!
SAVE ME!
uh oh. ohh everything's changed now
UH Blake- I don't- Blake doesn't know Blake doesn't know
Blake doesn't KNOW
mmruhh
mmrih
MMRAWR
[strained] mMRAIR
Blake shouln'ta ate sO MANY DONUTS
ow, ow, do I do anything about that?
fuck
oh!
oh GOOD I'm back in reality!
[nervous laughter] hhuuuuhh where am I
oohhhhhh
"Interact"? Oh wait what am I supposed to do with this where am I supposed to push it
okay WELL that was an adventurous time
Let's review what we got
"The mine entrance is usually on the top floor"? Wh-how do you know that??
"I have lots of friends"
[garbled backwards talk]
*sigh* I dunno I dunno I dunno I DUNNNOOOO
I DON'T KNOW
*sigh* I dunno, but at least I think I got everything in there.
Okay, so we gotta...
So we can't go through here because it's all blocked up anyway. This is-
Wait, this is exactly where I was, wasn't it?
Then I didn't make it very far- or maybe I did
God, I just have no idea anymore with all this stuff.
Okay, so--
I think I can go up there.
Looks like a place I can go... maybe.
Maybe it's not.
I- Like my- my ability to determine where I've been and where I've gone is just
thrown out the window when we keep being tossed in and out of reality like this
whhhhhy?
wh-
okay, good thing I haven't taken much DABLAGE!
Still raining blood though which is, ya know, very confenient.
CONFENIENT not CONVENIENT. I like consistency in my life.
I like CONFISTENCY in my life.
eugh, I don't like confistency
[very quietly] hello, hi, okay
Well don't try to spook me unless you're actually trying to spook me here  (you´re playing outlast 2 mark wtf)
oh this is where...
wait..
hi
ok...
maybe... It all looks the same so it's hard to tell
where I've been and-
[loud grunting noises]
OHHHHHYE
AY YI YI YI YI
HI HI HI HI
AH YI YI YI YI YI
oh
ouh
ohnononononononononoononono no need to go
back there
no need to go back there
alright
Let's not be screaming like a little bitch baby until we know what we need to scream at
(what??)
ouh boi
Sounds like there's a lot to scream at over here
ok, alright!
[making poppy poopy noises with his mouth]
c'mon.. okay
I'm a brave boi x3
There ain't nothin wrong here
Wait, ooouuuhhhkay
Opening this...
Like a BAWS
I hear a lot of things..
I just don't see a lot of things
OH
I SEE A LOTTA THINGS
I see a someone over there
oh, hi, okay, where is this going?
I don't know this is going
Where's this going?
OH GOD
WHERE'S THIS GOING?
WHERE'S IT GOING?
I DON'T KNOW
OOOH I DID THIS WRONG!
OOooOOEeUGHHGH I DID THIS WRONG
OKay I think I need to push it out there, maybe?
I don't know where this is going
OH MAYBE I SHOULD CLOSE THIS
REUGHR
REEEEUGHHRH
oh I see it
I see it x3
oh kayy
I closed that...
So hopefully I'm gonna be okay
[loud screaming from monsters]
They can't see to get to me,
which is good, they're just making a lot of noises, which is good
Good, they're exercising their vocal cords! They're doing all their vocal warm ups!
That's good, you can't- OH HI!
OKAY ALRIGHT HEUGH HEH HEGH HEH HEH
NOOOoOOoOoO
NAAHHHOOOWWOOO
NO I WAS UP THERE
NO GET UP THE THAAIIING
so uuuUUuuhhHhhHhhhhhhhh
that was dumb
That was real dumb
That was real dumb, huh?
That was dumb!
Dumb!
Dumb dumb dumb!
OKay so I don't need to close that off if I just need to get this out there quicker
uhhhhh
And I need to ACTUALLY get this on the wall there
And not miss my jump like an IDIOT
Okay like THAT and then go up there
OOOOooooo Hey
Hohhhh
Aiiiiiiiyayayayaya
HI
Hello (It's me)
AYYYYY WOOOW FKING GOD DAMN IT
Ay YOU GOD DAMN IDIOT
YOU ASSHOLE
DOUCHESNOZZLE
PIECE OF GARBLE- Where am I going?
HWOOOPTI
WELL that was not correct, I THINK
I dunno where I'm going
Where am I going x2
Whe- AYE! WHAT?
Wh- It's impossible to see where I'm going
When everything looks the saaame
Okay, here we go again I guess
Geezums!
Everything looks the same
Everything IS the same
How am I supposed to know where I'm supposed to jump?
oOH Nelly!
Oh I'm supposed to CRAWLLL
Ohh okay!
Oh man
It may just be my panicked brain not taking in that information
But it just, it's a little bit difficult
Just a little bit difficult
And these Heretics, they want me bad
NO!
WHA- I- I was very clearly on the ramp
Oh no x5
Where th- where the frick did I go
Oh boy, oh bo-
OW! NOOO!
NOOOOOOOOOO
Oh boy x4
Something I-
This is ridiculous okay? This is just a little bit ridiculous
Okay? This is just a little bit ridiculous.
Okay? I just wanna say that right now It's a little bit ridiculous.
Because I am very clearly doing the things that I intend to do
And it is not doing it back to ME!
It's not treating ME with the respect that I deserve
Alright I'm gonna stop whining and complaining
And I'm actually going to play this better
Okay. So.
I need to walk across this very slowly right?
I got it x4
It's all good! x3
I got this
Aw, Easy Peasy!
Ha! Easy sneezy
oop
Ya I can do this
OH Hey! Oh hey, what's up?
Walking to my neighborhood
Okay here we go
♫ Paying attention to where I'm going where I'm going YES YES YEEEEESSSSSS ♫
Okay we're good, we're good, we're good.
We're GOOD x3
OOOOOooo AHHHHH
OOOOOOoooo
HIIIIII?
uhhhhh
huh?
WH-
What
Oh
Okay
Uhhhhh Okay
Alright
UH
Uh
Okay!
Well I guess it's make sense considering in the real world I'll be still be running away!
UHHHHH
Uh
Okay
Okay where am I going?
Just pulling open a bunch of mystery doors here,
is that what I'm doing?
Looking for places to hide,
Is that what I'm doing in the real world?
Oh, boy.
I wonder what the heretics think of me as I'm babbling.
Like, just completely lost of where
I'm supposed to be going. I don't-
I DON'T THINK I WAS SUPPOSED TO DO THAT
Ah, yeah. That wa- That's not what I was supposed to do
Ah. I was being VERY dumb.
Oh, hey, how's it goin'?
Alright, so, if that's not what I was supposed to do then...
Maybe what I was supposed to do is not go in that bathroom at ALL
Or, hide in one of the stalls
Which is entirely possible
Let's try this once more without being too incredibly stupid...
So, I'm obviously supposed to go in here...
So, let me try hiding in one of the stalls.
Oh, they'll never check the one at the end! *sarcasm*
Oh...
Uh oh...
Uh oh.
Uh oh. Uh oh. Uh oh.
Uh oh! UH oh!
Hey?! Oh god! Oh! What was I supposed to do there??? Ohhh. What was I supposed to do??
Oh! I know! I could crawl under them.
I didn't even think of that!
Oh, I didn't even think of that!
I could probably crawl under them, couldn't I?
Okay, alright, we're getting somewhere. I'm gonna keep this down just because the warping is a little bit disorienting for me.
I know it's gotta be disorienting for some of you guys
BAAAAAYUM BABY I WENT INTO THIS HALLWAY NOW! And, anyways,
So, I could probably, if I start over here,
I might be able to crawl under these, but I'm not 100% sure about that.
Nope... This was not correct oh no.
Maybe when it hits... Maybe when it hits I gotta open it
To smack into him.
Yeah, that's what I gotta do... Oh yeah...
Oh, yeah. I gotchu. Oh, yeah. I gotchu
SMASH YOU! SMASH YOU, BITCH! SMASH YOU, BITCH!
BAM! AHHHHH! That wasn't it...
That was not the right answer... That was not the right answer
So... What am i supposed to do about that?
Maybe... Woah! What the fuck?!?
Wait, what?? Why am I here?? WHy am I here??
I don't know why I'm here but, okay. That doesn't make a lot of sense, but okay. I'll take it! I'll take the victory for when I got it!
did I just terrifically broke the game or something?
Which was entirely possible, but maybe not.
What the fuck just happened?
Oh okay! Alright! Whoa...
Hi.
oooh jeez
OOOOOOH JEEZ
Anything up there?
Anything up there I'm supposed to see?
*character panic pants*
Anything?
*music intensifies*
NOPE
Pretty sure I was supposed to go down that one
ooohh I'm dumb
Okay which way?
aH
uuuuhh okAy?
Alright thank you for clarifying
I think...
I"m not trying to hide, I'm running. There's a distinct difference.
Uh-oh
No I don't think so
I don't need your help!
I don't think anyone needs your help
Hello.
I'll Never Let You Go
okaY
goOd?
maybe goOd?
Am I supposed to go out the window again? This is where I came in?!
I think I am supposed to go out here?
yeah i am
ho!
*blood rain falls from the heavens*
oOh
Blake: Help
Ok
We're out here now
apparently...
this is good
A good welcome change to what we were doing out there
*whining* idontknowwhatishappeningggggg
Alright...
Can I go down?
Can I jump down or something?
Okay I think I'm supposed to climb over to the right maybe?
I don't even know how I got here
I mean it LOOks like I'm supposed to be able to drop down over there but...
maybe not
No?
C-can I
C-can I drop down please, I'd like to get off this  *voice breaks like a tween* wild ride
*whines* I wanna get off Mr. Bone's Wild Riiiiide
Please?
Let me drOp
There we go, okay got it
Alright
Gotta press the crouch button to drop
whoa
that's a little skeezy
Ho!
wait w-wHAt are you doing?
Don't get do scared that you spstart backtracking on me!!
that's...
*banging noises*
Something tells me I-
*banging noises pt2*
Something tells me I shouldn't go
*banging noises pt3*
I shouldn't go over there
I'm gonna get knocked off
Alright here we go
Blake: oomf
oookay that barely worked
Okay?
Blake: *grunts*
oh boy
Hard to see everything in the raining blood
Was there anything else I was supposed to document there?
There was nothing I coulda documented in the dream world
The quote on quote "dream world" that might be even more real than this world here
jeez
*sigh* iduunnoman, i don't know
Jeez
*sounds of rain falling on metal*
Okay there's gotta be a place to go
...from up here
Buut as far as I can tell-
ah! here we go
oh!
well HANDY that
oh..
hi?
Are you still coming after me?
You guys are really swarming this place
I don't know why I'm that interesting to you just cuz
I'm the father of the antichrist or something like that
shoobdy
Blake: *screams*
ooooww
Blake: *grunts*
Owieee, my coccyx
HEY OKAY
alright what do i do what do i do
okay ims gonna go this way now
ooooh boy
oh boy Still running
still running, oh boy
oh boy
come on x4
roll faster please
faster x3
okay
nothing to worry about just act cool, calm, and collected.
get your crack cocaine on
oooh no oh no
where? x4
up up up up, always up
it's either up or down no matter what I say
kay here we go now come on x3
you can stand up at any time now
jeez
this guy here
little farther come on
come on!
yeah theres a biG stRoNg Boi
BAM baby!
okay good
okay good...
okay good!
we made it to the top which is somehow...
*elevator gears and some other banging*
somehow the TOP is the entrence to the MINE which goes into the earth
don't ask me why that makes sense because it does not.
it's still raining blood
no idea why that's happening but it's still raining blood
and I still haven't been injured just because I've been KILLED every single time I've try to do something so
*sigh* well let's just go into the mine because that's obviously what we need to do next
Ah last time i was in an elevator
it's coming?
What's coming?
The elevator?
Am I not in the elevator?
*elevator gears and some other banging*
Am I not..
Am I not in the elevator?
Uh-oh...uh-oh-uh-oh..uH Oh x7
oh no x4
*growl* AH
AYEAYEAYEAYE
uh oh x3
OW
What was I supposed to do??
*growls of the damned*
what kinda BS was that??
okay was i suppoed to call them and then-
oh no
I can't move
Oh
wHy did THAT happen?
I didn't see that happen!
You're just gonna do things to me and not tell me about the things you are doin?
ya
son of a bitch
why did i even bother that?
I think I gotta cycle round and eventually make my way back there
that's a little bit bullshit
*sigh*
gotta keep moving though
just gotta stop complaining and keep moving
I'm more complaining for the sake of Blake here because he has to deal with all this.
He has to go through multiple reincarnations as he dies over and over again
to my own stupidity
so I'm not complaining for my sake, I'm complaining for Blake here
okay so  yeah so i gotta circle back round
but ow apparently i'm going slow now
Why?!
Stop going slow and just hurry the heck up!
oh no...come on are you joking me right now?
Are you KIDDING ME? RUUUN
*growling*
Oh yes slow and steady wins the race, don't it?
YEAh
OH YEAH
NOW'S THE TIME TO BE OUTTA SHAPE
*growling continues*
frick a dick and fuck you guys
Poor Blake I guess, he is running on what've gotta be fumes at this point
because he's got so much blood loss, so many broken bones, so many bruises and he's been sprinting since he got here
you know it's actually  not all that amazing that he might be running out of steam
Yeah her name IS Lynn
Her name is indeed Lynn
Soft?
80ft
Alright
I love elevator rides
Oh good of course it gets stuck
Every elevator in EVERY horror game EVER gets stuck, falls down. Even in the original Outlast. This happened
WEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
oOW
Some how that didn't kill me
oh boy i better get out of here
can i get outta here?
I-I tried, I tried, I really tried...
I tried there
oh boy
oooh
wow.
okay
Okay?
800 ft down
uuuhhh
Blake: *struggles to breathe*
OkkAy
I guess this is my stop
yeesh
Alright here we go, don't fall on my head plz
yoop
whOOOa it almost fell on my head
How did I call that one?
*sigh of relief* ah, good, oof
though that was gonna be BAD for me
thought that was gonna be
BAD
but alas I'm too smart for you
alright let's see what this means
*exasperated exhale*
alright
yeah
i got that
well that's awfully nice to think about
in your own demise
are you talking about Jessica or are you talking about Lynn though? (ooooo)
oh I did miss one, i dont know where i missed it
*sigh* probably in the ONE second that I put my camera down
aw man
or probably actually it happened when uh, it mighta bugged out and i-it set my save a little bit farther than I actually was
Which is a little bit oooDuh
oh well, that's fine
*exasperated sigh*
I haven't been completionist yet but
Note: completionist is a player who attempts to complete every challenge and earn every achievement or trophy
*concerned* hi?
Hello??
I-I am in the center of the heretic abode right now
so i am in the heart of their entire operation
So at this point,
i´m kind of invading THEIR sanctum, so
All righty then 2x
ooooOOOOOHH nooOOooo
oh no
*nervous laugh*
Lynn?
I'm coming, Lynn...
uh
What are they doing to her
I mean, The Heretics want her to have the baby
That´s the idea
If there even is a baby, which even the Lynn was kinda like...
maybe there´s a baby
It´s probably not even my baby
Maybe's it's gonna be one of those circumstances where
like
I know I'm not-not trying to accuse her or anything but like...you know
oh okay
Alright then well we'll do it-
I d-dont know what the hell happened there
But uuhh we're just gonna do this like this
WAiT
But
WaiT
w-
w-w-w-why're you
okAy?
Alright that was weird...
wut
W-why was that happening?
w-what's that?
eugh what Is that
what is that, is that a skull or-
What is that?
what IS that
what kinda animal is that, is that a goat head?
I have no idea
EuGh
oh boy
Well there's a nice body...
oOh GoOOOoD
OOoh cruMbliNg
gOoooOd
ooooooh boy
lettme go the dark path first...nothing there
nothing in the crumbles-Oh...
hi
i hear those footsteps
oOk
alrighty then
here we gooooo...
f-fuck
o-OkAY oh I thought it was gonna be something terrifying
and something i haven't seen before
it's just YOU *close up of meat*
how ya doing buddy?
you look good
ooooh boy
Mark: Lynned
Blake: "I had to find Lynn. I hoped I hadn't already."
Well that's obivously not Lynn
Lynn wasn't that buff and muscular
I mean I know they just flayed the skin and all that but
NAw
come on
think that's lynn?
no way
*sigh*
hello
oh GOOD a sacrifical pit of some sort
oh cannibalism, oh goOd, oh great!
omma go in that hole
in just a second
I just wanted to make sure I found everything I needed to find
here we gooooooooooooooo
oh battery!!
oooooooh that's incising I want that
lettme REloooad
I'll grab that battery and then we'll be-
along the way
why is everything marked by blood? EVERYTHING is marked by blood.
Every escape route, every single way that everybody's ever gone, marked by blood
outside? RAINING BLOOD
in here?! blood EVERYWHERE
oh, in your food? BLOOD
ok
good stuff through and through
oh boy
hi
Oh. More batteries.
I guess they're expecting-*surprised gasp* Hey...
hey
how ya doin there?
don't look immediately behind you
yeah that wouldn't be the thing you were looking for
why did I do this?
oh maybe i need to hide because they're a comin'
yeh this bowl of water seems like a good idea
why did I do this?
okay
so i just need to sit here cuz...they're a comin'?
maybe?
cuz there was the lockers over there would've been a better place to hide but-
hi
i'm just kinda
I'm tryin'
okay I think I'm fine
I think I'm fine
ok
oaky
*yelling to imaginary string quartet* Strings can you calm down for one GODDAMN second I'm trying to be quiet and then you start DINGDANGING
FUCKING GAHD DAMMIT
*blabbering*
ah
*yelling to imaginary string quartet* Strings can you calm down for one GODDAMN second I'm trying to be quiet and then you start DINGDANGING
FUCKING GAHD DAMMIT
*blabbering*
Okay maybe you string quartet was trying to warn me about something here but I still don't appreciate it none
*sigh* aalright
is there something i need to be afraid of out there?
is there SOME reason I needed to crawl into this hole and hide?
please tell me that it is that way that is and i'm not being a big dumb idiot
OkAY
imma trust you on this one
i'm trustin' ya!
D-Don't douche me over like this
dont douche me over
once i grab Lynn and everything is gonna be honky dory and I'm gonna get outta-
AHHH FCKING HI
just don't douche me over
okay that's gonna locked that's probably the way I'm gonna be coming back
once i grab Lynn and everything is gonna be honky dory and I'm gonna get outta-
AHHH FCKING HI
WHAT?
Are you KiDdIng ME?
it's a surprise Door O' DEath?
REaaaaLLY?
You're gonna dick me over with a surprise door o death?!!!
oh jooooooy
oh frabjous day
kay you're there
that mean you're coming this way or you going that way?
ok
OH
I was supposed to SEE that he went throught there
*screams of the damned*
man this has BEEN the most jumpscary episode of this entire game
Impressive?
*exasperated sigh*
*screams of the damned*
OkAY?
Impressive?
that's the only thing i can think to say at that point
eugh
Can you hold very still?
what am I looking at??
eugh
o-OH, I NEED TO RECORD SOMETHING
Can you hold very still?
*laughs*
Hold still!
NONO GOD DAMMIT I WAS trying To GEt SOmETHINg
just kill me, just kill me
*laughs*
OH!
Where am I?
we're starting here
REALLY??
I nEed to RecOrd, I'll be back
Where am I?
Oh my god
*ded again*
You are god damn joking me gaaaame
when did you get so douchetastic??
Wheeen?
When did you get so douchey?
gAaaMEe
When did you decide to douche it up 100,000x??
*laughs*
DUUUDE
UGH
Alright close this, lock it, I suppose...
*laughs*
Oooooh my God
OH!
COME ON!
NOOOO!!
You gotta be kidding me
*laughing* Oh you've gota be joking me
All I can do is laugh...all I can do is laugh!
NOOOO!!
You gotta be kidding me
*laughing* Oh you've gota be joking me
All I can do is laugh...all I can do is laugh!
I've died more times in this episode than I've died in this entire God Damn game
uGh
I don't get a moment's respite
and my god if this didn't crank up to maxium douchetry *laughs*
Imma go hide in here I suppose
sure
Maybe this isnt a good one to be in, maybe this one is
ayeayeayeayeaye
ayeayeayeayeayeayeayeayeayeaye
ooooh man, I'm not actually-I'm not angry at the game
I'm not angry at the game, I'm just amazed, I'm amazed at it, I'm amazed at its level of douchetry
well good thing i switched lockers
and good thing they're not very thorough
STRING QUARTET!!!
Are you KIDDING me Right now??
'kay Imma
Imma go for it, I think I can hurdle over that board right in front of me, right there
I think I can hurdle-
over that
cuz it doesn't seem like she's gonna let me....
she doesn't seem like she's gonna walk away, so here we go!
HEY i was right x3
ooo I can do that-
AW NO! Not there!
oh boy
okay, let's just keep going
keep going I don't know where we're going!
Oh NO not that way!
*groooooan*
Didn't see nothing did ya??
string quartet let me know when it's cool
imma heal
they're checking the thing again?
oh my god nice ass
that is quite the buttocks
what am I supposed to do about this?
no what're weird
oh my god nice ass
that is quite the buttocks
okay but he's gone
he's leaving
so that's good
so that means...
maybe
make my way down
this way
OOP no I can't!
hOOW?
What do i do??
there's no way to go around circularly unless I can lead him around here
HEY! Okay you're gonna follow me! You're gonna ring around the rosey baby
why??
okay here we go
Now we go x4
OH GOD DAMMIT WHY?
why??
I needed to record that other thing!
AH it was down the OTHER way
frick a dick, frick my dick, and frick that dick
frick that-oh no he's here
oh yeah x2
recording it
recording it, don'creep up on me
don't be a douche x5
Now we can go!
YEEEES
okay
Now we go!
Now we can go!
where are we?
oh
ooo
don't know what that's gonna do
oh
shit
ooo
maybe not shit?
maybe good?
oh
wait no
okay
so i need to let this go a little farther
and then divert it
maybe push it the other way
so let me pull this
and then switch it
and then hopefully that will lead me down the right path
right?
or maybe i need to go the LEFT way because pushing this long distance would make the most sense
is there anything over there that i needed?
oh there probably was, wasn't there?
lettme jsut..
*groans*
you know what I'm just gonna go this way because i feel like this is the secret
and it was
like cuz this seems...i dont know
i-it's impossible to say which way is the right way and which is the wrong way to go
tell you WhAaT?
oh no this is the end way to go
You're gonna wax poetic?
i'll be right back
You're right
Hello...
You're gonna wax poetic?
Let's keep going
Oooo what's that?
Hello...
*reads note in Knoth's voice*
ThIS is the secret!
aAah
and THANK YOU FOR THAT
*reads note in Knoth's voice again*
Well that's  pleasant  thought to end this episode on but I FOUND IT
So GOOd FoR ME
and THANK YOU FOR THAT
eugh
anyway
so
that's all the time I've got for this episode here
we did fine some things, I tried to be as thorough as I could be
but even in the panic and the-the ENDLESS cycle of death that I was subjected to
I still missed one or two things
so, sorry about that, but I'll try to do better in the next episode
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know how I'm doing in the comments bellow
And as always I will see YOU in the next video!
Buh-bye!